thanks for joining us America Sal is
with us in America and sale there he is
in Savannah Georgia hey Sal how are you
I'll get a tour and Dave thanks for
having me
Sherman what's up so right now my wife
and I are currently taking the classes
and we are about to do week six tonight
but just a few days ago so we have a
Jeep
their only vehicle but we have a $35,000
loan on it for 2012
whatever has a few days ago we traded it
in to get a vehicle that was like 5500
that I was just reliable my wife felt
safe in with our son and we took the hit
of the negative equity which was around
eighty eight hundred for us that's about
a fifteen thousand dollar loan
unfortunately the people who gave us a
loan they retracted and said we're not
going to pay the dealership this money
because the from the loan to value ratio
the loans way too high for the value of
the vehicle so we just had to give it
back and take our Jeep back so I'm just
trying to figure out how because this
Jeep is really the biggest thing that's
killing us in our in our debt I mean
it's called for six hundred and nine
dollars a month so I'm really just
trying to figure out what's the best way
to get away from this I'm wondering if I
want your house holding them for T
around 42,000 okay
and who's the loan with on the jeep the
lawn right now is with Regions Bank and
go sit down in person with Regions Bank
and talk to them about signing a note
for the difference of what the Jeep
won't bring the $8,000 now it will be
less than $8,000 because you're going to
sell the Jeep personally rather than
trade it in so it's probably going to be
more like $5,000 all right because you
can get a lot more for it selling it
yourself and that's what you need to do
because you can't you can't afford to
take the hit on doing it as a trading
I'm glad the other deal didn't work out
in other words now then that's gone now
what what cars do you have your two cars
are just the Jeep now that's that's the
only one we have it's the only vehicle
you own okay then
also talk to the credit union about
making you a separate loan for a basic
little car like you were trying to buy a
while ago the $5,000 car so that's going
to put you in about the same position
the other deal would have put you in
except a little bit less debt because
you're going to sell the Jeep yourself
okay and but you've got to work this out
with your credit union it's going to be
your best shot to let you sign a note
for the difference and then let get them
to give you a car loan to get you by now
how many kids do you have we have one
son and one on the way okay well
congratulations thank you appreciate it
well you do need something quote unquote
safe and reliable it may be that you end
up going even cheaper than five thousand
because you might have to work overtime
to just buy it in cash to make this deal
work later and it may take you a few
months to put all this together yeah I
can't really work all the time now
because I'm a active-duty military so
it's not exactly like they let you do
that I got you yeah okay alright but uh
well I think you've gonna it's gonna
take you a little while to whittle your
way through this yeah it took a while to
make the mess and it takes a while to
clean the mess up yeah definitely and it
was definitely a horrible decision for
this from the get-go but uh hey I'm
sorry go ahead
just just say it doesn't work out with
the credit union now do you think an
option would be move my Jeep up to my
number one priority on my desk no ball
to pay off the negative equity as fast
as possible and which other debt do you
have um I have about I have two car loan
to school loans out there one of them is
20 grand the other ones only around like
twenty one hundred I have left on it and
have like two credit cards left that
have around two thousand on them as well
yeah I would look at the $8,000 or
$6,000 hole that you're in as the thing
so before I got to the twenty thousand
dollar loan I would move it up to that
level okay instead of being your largest
debt I'd make it your next two largest
debt and look at it look at it as an
$8,000 or $6,000 debt because that's
paying it down to get it right side up
so you can get it sold
yeah okay thanks for your service to the
country sir we appreciate yourself
god bless open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right I got a theme this hour have you
heard it people buying cars they can't
afford did you hear the theme I heard it
sometimes God just gives us a theme we
didn't even need a theme our it's just
right there I mean the last two or three
callers it just makes you want to go do
what and yet I've done it's dumb a thing
and so of you but let me give you a rule
of thumb here if you want to be broke
your entire life if you never want to be
wealthy spend your money on cars that'll
make you broke it's the largest thing we
buy that goes down in value and they go
down in value like a rock that's where
Chevy got that like a rock Fords know
better it's found on the road
depreciated shut up they all go down in
value the average car loses 60 to 70% of
its value in the first four years you
own it absolute insanity well I'm buying
a Mercedes they don't go down in value
crap they don't a buddy of mine bought
one of those SUVs Mercedes nice one 550
GL nice one $90,000 $85,000 car you know
what in 2008 you know what it's worth
right now
20 he turned you just turned 80,000
bucks into 20,000 and you scratch your
head you wonder why you're broke now in
his case he's a multi-millionaire and he
can afford to do that it doesn't even
show up on his radar but you know most
people did that crap all the time these
people buying $60,000 worth of car loans
I make $55,000 a year
Sal's making 40,000 about $35,000 gee
now yeah he said it was stupid he's
right it was stupid so I'm not picking
on Sal I'm gonna pick on the decision
though I was already picked on the
decision he agrees with me is stupid you
go by crap that's
got engines in it it goes down in value
you cannot afford to do that until you
have some wealth now I've got cars and
I've got some nice cars and that's fine
I've got the money now but when I was
broke you know what I drove yeah
predominant color on the puppy was bondo
it was a $400 car was my car after
bankruptcy but I never borrowed money
again I saved up money and got $1,000
card it was a sizable increase in value
listen you know you're a redneck driving
a hoopty if when you put tires on your
car you double the value of the car okay
I've done that and I lived like no one
else now I can live like no one else I
drove like no one else people made fun
of people have always made fun of
whatever I drive now they're mad because
I've got nice cars they used to be mad
because I drove hoop tease can't believe
you drive a piece of crap Ramsey can't
believe you spend all that money on cars
just hungry children somewhere there's
always somebody got an opinion about
other people's stuff have you noticed
some of you people need a mind your own
business and shut the flip up there's an
idea
so I mean really but the deal is this I
am think about cars now I'm a boy I love
cars
most of us boys love cars I get that
buddy mine was just in here a few
minutes ago got an AMG 550 with a rentec
on it sucker oh goes he wrote it that
thing to take off and go the moon it's
so fast it's unbelievable sweet car all
I mean I I'm a boy I love cars but let
me just tell you I'm also a math guy and
a financial guy and I hate cars because
they go down in value like a rock
anybody tells you that the car holds its
value laugh at them in their face I left
it you you're a fool because none of
them hold their value boats don't hold
their value airplanes don't hold their
value motorcycles don't hold the value
four-wheelers of snowmobiles and
sea-doos don't order their value if you
put a freaking engine in it it drops
like a rock in value and we spent all
our money on that so putting money and
things that go up in value and then we
scrap
and the richest society the world has
ever seen and wonder why we're broke and
can't retire without the government
taking care of us because you spent your
freaking money on depreciating assets
called a car stop it
$600 car payment but the flip were you
thinking oh you weren't see this is how
we're doing in this culture it's time to
wake up you're impressing people to stop
like you will never meet and if the girl
is impressed with what you drive you got
the wrong girl Bubba Wow
think people think stuff is destroying
your finances this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you